yeah welcome to this video playing Eric
kofsky at least it's spanish flag so the
center counter with all the scandinavian
put twenty six cats this is quite a
respectable line nowadays of course i
don't know it in any detail hmm let's
try to develop maybe g3 support some
later bishop a form i wonder if d for
such a great move him maybe I could but
to h6 isn't is very slow what he's doing
here yeah probably it doesn't matter if
if he is going to play me six of course
and after that it's a very young very
closed I mean close to start the right
word but hard to break up break open
this position with d 45 hmm hmm maybe I
need to do something entirely different
here let's try this one it's an
interesting move intending b5 rock p1
play against here the queenside
the idea is that the bishop on f5 is not
defending the Queen side anymore my
bishop on g2 is what
just just giving up the exchange like
that okay
yeah I need supply rook c8 now the only
okay I thought rook c8 at least looks
like some compensation not enough
compensation but at least it's something
came in so let's see how to do this now
it's not completely easy because is
still got some active pieces left it for
this before unfortunately young d3
Bishop t 292 something like that maybe
you can go down this booth f3 there's
this check you know I cannot do cannot
play somewhere else can it's it's not
such a big deal this some also gives me
some time p.m. at least back to waiting
the position of it
this winning of the exchange of course
cost some time Bishop AAA to take its
return and so on so this is some how he
got some some activity
so the plan now is to use the sepan see
form try to make an passport out of that
and see 400 prob'ly need to prepared and
ce4 next
so he's got a pawn for the exchange
playing really without calculating too
much h3y book was very interesting the
snide did never square but anyway this
threatens on b5 it's not so easy to
answer so on no see five years come on
let's get this porn ruling
the h3 is probably sucking a piece of
Queen g three hours I've rock f3 this is
important I don't want to allow takes
Knight xcent some threat I guess he
needs to SEC another piece top night h6
g4 is just just completely lost without
any any kind of play
night h5 is another move Queen takes
Knight takes g3 kingi one member debted
ok yeah no threatening g5 and he's got
no activity whatsoever yeah g five wins
apiece don't see them I take it well
this is stupid ok come on keep it keep
it simple threatening made on just a
flight now it needs to exchange Queens
yes but at the end of the Streif five
now get the night a ticket takes you
five takes to 70 this is not entirely
clear ok take this it's probably the
easiest and this is hanging so let's
make sure that I win it well let's let's
let's play it this way this is also good
restricting the night and this whence
the ape on anyway
is
yeah I cannot move any of the pieces
just go to g6 now I to gphone oh I'm
sorry hmm yeah no reason not to take it
check
Oh should I just take it I mean this is
winning yeah come on I just take it and
know the H bowl
black resigns yeah maybe you had
something but okay I also missed missed
a couple of easy moves i think around
here again now just h3y not age three
now you can't take on g3 I didn't I
didn't calculate anything here but this
is not so easy and this is a funny point
hmm yeah it's not easy at all this is
this even losses hmm ok so this was good
that I avoided that yet here Roxy forest
the comm move but isn't age 3 good as
well our queen takes g3 is the best
chance according to the comp it's the
losing button well this is very very
bleak yeah this was was just the easiest
get rid of the Queen's with their with
the somewhat open King position this is
probably the the wisest decision and
this is really just a winning end game
ok thanks for watching